pour se réaliser des cas besoin de mixer
les genres et les médias d'intégrer les
technologies les plus contemporaines à
son art l'artiste pluri média présente
son exposition hymne aux mobiles à la
maison de l'étang de louveciennes
peintures sculptures installations un
travail éclectique mais qui reste axée
autour de la thématique de l' équilibre
s'est trouvé dans une sculpture de 1,1
point d'équilibré
là il y en a une on se développe ça
tient oui ça tient mais ça pourrait
s'écrouler et une toile c'est pareil il
y a il ya un équilibre il ya un
équilibre entre les entre les couleurs
entre les le la disposition de la
couleur sur la sur la toile la façon
dont ça a été disposé il y à une
installation derrière avec des miroirs
un jeu de courants d'air des led pour sa
bouche pour qu'il ya un retour sur le
plafond de la lumière on voit de la nuit
donc tout est question d'équilibré
après une formation aux beaux arts est
en école de design deck de son vrai nom
christophe julien allie travail sur bois
résume pierre toile et lun une réflexion
sur les effets de matière et de
contraste pour jouer avec les volumes
le volume est important et je pense
qu'une exposition pour qu'elle soit
vivante aujourd'hui il faut également
intégrer une mise en scène et c'est vrai
que je fais également la mise en scène
de mes expositions et c'est vrai qu'on
est dans des salles les sadia des murs
donc pour habiller les murs mais il ya
des espaces entre les murs cette
exposition est à découvrir jusqu'au 12
juin à louveciennes prochain rendez-vous
dans les yvelines pour l'artiste à
partir du 16 janvier à l'espace des arts
de villennes sur seine